Speaker 1: The Republican National Committee
is now joining Donald Trump and others in
desperately trying to keep their own email
records away from the Jan. six committee investigating
the Trump riots of 2021.
Once again, this is not the behavior of parties
who have nothing to hide.
CNN report.
RNC tries to stop 2020 email communications
data from going to the January 6th Committee
on Wednesday.
The House Select Committee investigating the
attack on the U.S. Capitol is poised to receive
data from the Republican Party's email communications
platform.
Salesforce, and the Republican National Committee
rushed to court last night to try to block
it.
The development is the latest to emerge about
the house's aggressive pursuits reconstructing
political misinformation after the 2020 election
that contributed to Trump supporters storming
the Capitol on January 6th.
The RNC alleges that the House subpoenaed
a salesforce seeking information about election
communications, including those related to
former President Trump.
Quote would give the select committee unprecedented
access to the RNC's internal political strategies
and to private personal information regarding
supporters, practically adding reasons that
their emails should be investigated.
What were they telling their big donors right
on the eve of the January 6th Trump riots,
political strategies which they want to hide
are exactly what got these people where they
are now.
Political strategies that involve lying about
election results, intimidation, calling for
violence, spreading fear and propaganda through
right wing media, trying to invalidate voters,
purge voter rolls, change vote totals send
AlterNet bogus slates of electors.
All of those things are why we're in this
mess.
And so the January 6th committee is 100 percent
right to say, hey, maybe they were talking
about that stuff in their email communications,
and if there isn't illegal stuff in there,
they don't really have anything to worry about.
I mean, everybody knows what the strategies
are.
You think we're going to learn about new strategies
by looking at their emails?
We know what the strategies are.
What we might learn is that they were openly
plotting and communicating about them with
donors and other higher ups.
The article goes on.
Last week, the RNC filed a lawsuit against
the House Committee complaining about the
Salesforce Salesforce subpoenas breath.
But that lawsuit was unlikely to succeed,
as it was aimed only at the committee, not
at Salesforce, and there is no emergency mechanism
to fast track it in court.
So Salesforce was planning to turn these records
over.
But now the RNC has added Salesforce to the
lawsuit.
Will they ultimately get those records?
I don't know.
We'll find out, you know, very soon.
But think of the irony and think of the hypocrisy
and the double standard.
The DNC emails were hacked.
You might remember that, and Putin told Trump
very strongly that it wasn't Russia, and Trump
believed him.
OK, whatever.
But the DNC emails were hacked.
And of course, Republicans didn't take the
high road.
They didn't.
They didn't say these were incorrectly released.
We're not going to use them.
They immediately use those emails for propaganda.
And here they are saying, Well, no, no, no,
no, no, it would be completely improper.
We're not talking about hacking.
We're done, but they're acting as though this
legal mechanism is worse than the hacking.
Really?
No, no, no, no, no.
It would be inappropriate to use that legal
mechanism to get these documents from us,
and the documents shouldn't, shouldn't be
released.
That would be wrong.
But when documents were hacked, they were
fine to use them and publicize them, et cetera,
et cetera.
And this is to be fair, to be fair, both sides
do this not to the same degree, but both sides
when there are documents that are made public.
If you don't like the content of the documents,
you focus on the impropriety of them being
made public.
If you like the content of the document, you
just focus on the content.
Democrats and Republicans, they all do this,
but they're not as hypocritical to this degree.
If they did nothing wrong, they should have
nothing to hide and it's more than that.
They should want to clear themselves of any
wrongdoing, even if their strategy gets out
to the committee.
They should be eager to prove we were not
involved in anything untoward or potentially
against the law.
Now what do I think is potentially going to
be exposed by these documents if they are
released on today's bonus show?
We're going to talk about what's going on
with Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas,
his wife, Ginni Thomas, Ginni Thomas.
We now have learned attended one of the January
6th events.
She attended the Jan. six rally before the
attack.
She wasn't at the attack, but she was at the
rally before the attack.
And Clarence Thomas Thomas has recently been
making statements about We don't want the
Supreme Court to become political.
I am.
Suspicious that part of what is now the kind
of next ring in these concentric circles around
the Trump riots is something that relates
to Jenny Thomas and thus has the potential
to pull in Clarence Thomas.
And we're going to talk about that a lot more
on today's bonus show.
They've gotten away with a lot of shenanigans
for a very long time.
And the Jan. six committee is right to go
after these email communications.
And let's hope that they get them.